you know it's fortunate that i linked up
with dmx before he passed away
and we became friends actually i think
um
who was up in there dana dane was at the
airport
me dmx and dana dane all had flights and
me and dmx squashed our situation and
became real good friends then man you
know i talked to him whenever i see him
he was all cool and
it was good that that happened before he
passed away get that just get that out
of the way you know what i'm saying me
and nas
i did a movie with ja rule you know i'm
saying half past dead
you know we got rid of our differences i
talked with erv
i talked with everybody that you know
um
that i shot at
uh with calling out names and got rid of
all of that you know
uh
all those issues and problems yeah yeah
it's crazy too because you were super
super so close to snoop dogg and snoop
dogg historically like we look back at
that time he had a lot of people in new
york that he was tight with and and from
what i've heard shook was not didn't
like that suganpak didn't like the fact
that he was
so cool with
a bunch of new york mcs